I remember David Cameron saying that he
was going to have it down to the tens of
thousands what's happened
well since that period we've had a
pandemic and the NHS has been given a
huge amount of money to recruit new
staff to help to catch up with the
consequences of that we've had the war
in Ukraine we've had the Crackdown from
China on people living in Hong Kong all
of which have meant that the UK has
stepped forward to do what it needs to
do either in the interests of our own
people and our economy or to help those
most in need in the world and that's why
those numbers are rise
are we doing what's up uh what the most
needy in the world want I'm obviously
reflecting on um stopping the boats
a large number of those who are in those
figures are people who fled through the
steam setup to support people from
Ukraine people who've been given the
right to come to the UK from Hong Kong
and of course people who continue to
come from Syria and Afghanistan and the
government's priority in line with the
expectations a lot of the voters have is
that that will be turned in a properly
managed way and of course if we look
simply at those people for example who
are coming here to work the vast
majority of those are coming to work in
the NHS and in our care sector both of
which are areas where there's a huge
priority to catch up with the
consequences of the pandemic and make
sure that people have the support and
the care that they need
and yet we still need more workers
according to Farmers than the like
that's entirely correct I certainly when
I hear from businesses in my
constituency the big thing that's
holding the back from growth is the
inability to recruit the staff that they
need so clearly we are going to need to
see a significant number of new arrivals
to fulfill those jobs we also need to be
training people in the UK in other parts
of the country encouraging them to move
to where the work is and it's going to
be a combination of those things in the
medium to long term that will make the
difference
so we should welcome
um significantly more people into the
country is what you're saying Mr Simmons
it is both an economic necessity and
part of a response which any sensible
government would have to the things that
are going on in The Wider world we need
to recognize that there are hundreds of
millions of people that are displaced
across the world by a combination of
natural disasters War conflicts
oppressive governments and the United
Kingdom as a global nation that is part
of the leading countries in the world
responding to make sure that we have as
much peace and stability as we can bring
about we'll need to do its part within
that which will include taking in some
refugees but the issue again with the
small boats is that we want to make sure
that that's done as we have seen through
for example the Ukraine scheme the
Syrian scheme the Hong Kong scheme
rather than happening in an uncontrolled
way in the hands of criminal games
just to clarify what the situation is
then as far as the conservative
Manifesto is concerned
um I'm sure that there was a limit in
numbers that we were told to expect
all governments sent out in Manifesto is
what they hope to achieve but of course
we've seen an unprecedented series of
world events since that Manifesto was
first but before the British people I
think people look around at what's
happened they've seen the effects of the
pandemic they've seen that the NHS is
recruiting huge numbers of doctors and
nurses to catch up with the consequences
of that they've seen that people with a
good solid connection to the UK like
people from Hong Kong like people who
served the British armed forces in
Afghanistan find themselves in Desperate
needs you'll have a right and
expectation to come to this country
they've seen what's happened with Excuse
me Vladimir Putin's invasion of Ukraine
and the UK like many other countries
across Europe has opened its doors to
refugees but many of whom in duporce
will want to go back to their home
country but whilst they're under direct
threat whilst there are bombardments
that we see on the news going on every
night and every day the British people
quite reasonably would say that those
people can find a place of safety a safe
haven here in the United Kingdom
you don't seem to be if I might say so
Mr Simmons in step with um some of those
within your party I'm thinking
particularly perhaps of the Prime
Minister and also the Home Secretary
public opinion varies on immigration I
represent a very diverse constituency
where we've seen people coming finding
refuge for generations and people are
very accepting of that well I fully
understand that somebody grew up in the
South Wales Valley is a place that was
not very Multicultural in the 1980s that
there are people who do have concerns
about the impact that that will have on
this country but immigration is a
long-term thing we need to have the
flexibility to respond to events that
happen in the world things like Wars
like natural disasters like like
pandemics and recognize that the
long-term aspiration is about a country
which has lower levels of uncontrolled
inward migration but recognizing that we
need a certain level of migration to
support our economy and to serve the
long-term needs and interests of the
British people
eloquently put but it doesn't seem that
the Home Secretary agrees with you
but the home secretary's job is to to
deal with these issues day to day and
clearly she's been setting out some
strategies in particular to address the
problem of small boats coming across the
Channel people were coming here at Great
risk to themselves in the hands of
criminal gangs and traffickers and
whilst it is reasonable to say let's
have a longer term aspiration to bring
the levels of migration into the UK
today we need to recognize that we are a
country which has a growing population
of people who need the care and support
of NHS workers those people who cannot
be found in the United Kingdom they
cannot be found in Europe and therefore
we need to go further Fields if we are
going to fulfill people's needs for care
and treatment and often people's legal
rights to care that they have under
British laws
um the Prime Minister let's talk about
him as well uh he says he wants to cut
Migration by half
um you're saying that's not what he
should be
um that's not what his ambition should
be at the moment
cutting immigration by half is probably
a reasonable aspiration because we know
if the work that we've been doing to
support Ukraine the the consequences of
what's happened in Afghanistan and
they're reducing numbers of people
coming from Hong Kong we're already
beginning to see reduction next numbers
comes about then the figure that we've
seen published for the last 12 months or
coming out this week for the last 12
months will reduce significantly
probably by half anyway but we do need
to make sure that the numbers arriving
for example foreign students who are
often a really important part of trade
deals education being a huge British
export and seeing countries like India
said it will be a condition of a trade
deal with the UK that they'd want to
have far greater access for their
students to British universities we need
to make sure that we have the
flexibility to do what we need to do to
support our economy to support our
people
Simmons predictions are that net
migration could be up to a million when
we see the figures on Thursday what's
your expectation
but that sounds not unrealistic and
given everything that's happened
specifically that we opened our doors to
people from Ukraine like many other
countries did we've supported
proactively people to work with our
armed forces in Afghanistan and people
from Hong Kong with long-standing
connections to the UK have been given
the right to come here all of which will
have added many hundreds of thousands to
that number so that certainly sounds
like a plausible Figure Set alongside
the huge recruitment Drive which the NHS
has been on recruiting doctors and
nurses from wherever they can be thanked
those things will contribute to a higher
figure in the short term
have you ever had a speeding fine that
you thought oh I want to go on a driving
course so that I don't have to take the
points
no
good for you well done I think most
people um have including the Home
Secretary
um it looks as though she potentially
has broken the ministerial code again
um what's your view
the prime minister is going to take
advice about what the appropriate Way
Forward is and I trust is Justin I think
he's set out very clearly how he
intended to deal with issues like this
and once he's got a sense of what the
facts are of the matter I'm sure that we
will take a sensible and balanced
approach
what's your view
my view is that the facts need to be
known we don't know whether this is a
smear campaign based on innuendo or
something that really is quite serious
and until we have those facts it's
simply not appropriate to make a
statement about the home secretary's
position no but if she's broken the uh
if she is found to have broken the
ministerial code again then you know
that's a bit careless twice in a year
isn't it
and if she hasn't then clearly the
situation is very different that's why
we need to know the facts
but if she has
but if she has yes indeed that would be
careless but as I say we have no idea
what's happened here at the moment we
just have a few small details that have
been reported and that's why I know the
Prime Minister will want to consider
exactly what's going on and we'll take
of you based on that that wider
knowledge of what's been like this